bonjour tout le monde oui je sais ce que
vous pensez oh la vache un chat noir il
va porter la bosse ça prouve que vous y
connaissez rien en chance
et maintenant un peu de culture la
chance n'est pas partout la même dans le
monde tenez en écosse croisé sur sa
route un chat noir comme moi est censé
porter chance surtout les enfants ne
faites pas ça chez vous je m'appelle bop
au fait et ça c'est la terre de la
chance aujourd'hui riz nous on travaille
en coulisse pour créer ces petits
moments de chance et de malchance qui
composent votre vie quotidienne
eu par exemple forment une équipe qui
imaginent des moments de chance ces
moments qui vous donne la pression ou
d'être les rois du monde peut bon
d'accord plutôt les rois du quartier et
puis bien sûr il y à l'autre équipe qui
travaille en rouge sur les mamans de
malchance et je vous assure qu'ils
adorent tout au
bout les humains vous êtes du genre
compliqué alors si les choses se passent
aussi bien ici c'est parce qu aucun
humain n'a jamais mis un pied dans cet
endroit et avec un petit peu de chance
et ne viendront jamais
je suis où exactement
au petit mois que c'est une blague
[Musique]